welcome back to Harbor unbox for another
Mega GPU Showdown feels like it's been a
while since we've done one of these
probably has something to do with ryzen
anyway on the menu for you today we have
a grand total of seven games ah just
kidding guys 27 games and they're all
tested at the 1080P and 1440p
resolutions obviously we're pitting the
new radon
rx580 against the new GeForce GTX 1060
this gaming X model from MSI that has
that faster 9 GBS per second memory and
then of course we will also be throwing
in the GeForce GTX 1060 the evj model so
that's the standard 1060 a little bit
confusing but that's the model we've
been using previously and we've also
been using the MSI gaming x uh rx480 for
testing previously as well all the
results were recorded in the past week
using the latest AMD and Nvidia display
Drive
so as I said 27 games have been tested
using four graphics cards at two
resolutions the results are based on an
average of three runs so that means over
600 Benchmark runs were made and this
video will be showing over 430
individual results last week I proposed
a list of 25 games to the harbor unboxed
patreon members and with a little back
and forth we ended up at 27 games those
of you that were Keen to see the results
of The Witcher 3 wild Hunt can thank
scoobydoo for his input there if you you
would like to become a harbor unbox
Patron and support the channel we would
very much appreciate that so I'll
provide a link in the video description
anyway back to the matter at hand our
mid-range GPU battle if you have $230 to
$280 to spend on a new graphics card
which should you get well we're about to
go and find out before we do though here
are a few things to note the graphics
cards used for testing include the EVGA
GTX 1060 for the win plus MSI GTX 1060
gaming X Plus and from the red team we
have the MSI RX 480 gaming x8g and the
Aus RX 580 extreme Edition the EVGA for
the win plus is very aggressively
overclocked from the factory featuring a
base clock speed of 1362 MHz meanwhile
the MSI gaming X+ comes clocked at 1569
MHz potentially making it 4% slower that
said the MSI model does feature 9 GB per
second gddr5 memory which means out of
the box its memory is clocked 12% higher
so it will be interesting to see what if
any kind of difference this makes
finally all testing was conducted using
our kbl Lake core i7 7700k test machine
overclocked to 4.9 GHz I'm sure there
will be dozens upon dozens of comments
asking for a retest using a ryzen CPU
and yes at some point down the track we
will do exactly that for now though
let's check out the numbers we have
gathered already responsible for more
dropped frames than A's catalyst drivers
Grand Theft Auto 5 is a game many of you
won't let me drop so starting things off
we have the oldest game tested and as
you can see it appears to favor the
Green Team looking at the 1440p results
we see the GTX 1060 was 177% faster than
the rx480 meanwhile the new RX 580
boosted amd's performance here by just
4% which meant they were still 14%
slower than the original GTX 1060
another Alie is The Witcher 3 wild Hunt
and again this is back due to popular
demand honestly I'll will probably be
testing this title Till The Witcher 4
comes out in a year or so's time this is
another title where the green team has a
slight advantage and yes we did test
with Hairworks enabled which does give
Nvidia a slight very slight Advantage
it's certainly not a big enough deal to
take to the comment section in protest
ah never mind too late there's already a
dozen comments isn't there anywh who as
you can see the RX 580 was 6% faster
than the RX x 480 which meant it was
still 6% slower than the GTX 1060s both
of which delivered the same average of
53 FPS we can't be too far away from
another tomb raid game either rumor has
it the game is being developed while
traveling on public transport a strategy
cryex likely to adopt for the
development of Crisis 4 we know that
rise of the Tomb Raider was developed in
conjunction with the green team but over
time AMD has been able to optimize their
hardware for this title quite well as a
result the rx480 is now just a few
frames behind the GTX 1060 while the
rx580 is able to match the new highspeed
9 GBS per second version right now there
are currently more people playing
Commander Conquer Red Alert 3 on Steam
than they are ashes of the singularity a
lot more this is probably why the gamers
earned the title ashes of The Benchmark
there could quite possibly be more
people benchmarking the game right now
than actually playing anyway in my
opinion the game is still one of the
best examples of a well put together
dx12 title we have though it is much
more useful for testing CPUs than it is
gpus the rx580 enjoys a slight
performance advantage over the GTX 1060
though for a dx12 title the margins are
hardly significant there are more than
twice as many people still playing
2014's Far Cry 4 when compared to the
more recent Primal version even so we
have stuck with the more modern title
for benchmarking the GTX 1060 was 5%
faster than the RX 580 while the 9 GB
per second version boost performance by
a further 3% so a slight Advantage for
NVIDIA here Tom clanes the division was
tested using direct X12 and Nvidia has
made up some ground with this API that
said the AMD gpus was still able to
snatch the lead and at 1080p the RX 580
was 8% faster than the enhanced GTX 1060
moving to 1440p Extended that lead and
now the RX 580 can be seen providing 11%
more performance another title which was
tested using direct X12 is Hitman and
here things are again very much neck and
neck again Nvidia has made great strides
recently in this title and as a result
even with dx12 enabled the GTX 1060 was
able to match the rx580 while managing
to pull ahead of the
rx480 AMD has made up quite a lot of
ground in Quantum break thanks to their
own driver development for testing we do
use the steam revision of the game and
AMD now looked to be providing stronger
performance in the direct X11 version
even so the RX 580 was still 4% slow on
the GTX 1060 though all four gpus did
push over 60 FPS when testing at 1080p
for testing OverWatch I use the same
5minute Benchmark used to measure CPU
performance so this is a 12 player bot
match the Epic quality preset was used
and the render scale was manually set to
100% here we see at 1080p the higher
clocked RX 580 makes up a good bit of
ground on the GTX 1060 while the higher
clocked 99 GBS per second version of the
GTX 1060 made difference and here it is
still the only demanding game to take
advantage of the Vulcan API no doubt
much to amd's dismay interestingly
evga's for the win plus was faster than
msi's gaming X+ model which utilizes the
higher clocked memory the margins
weren't significant though the EVGA
version was about 4% faster at typ
anyway what's key to note here is just
how much faster the radon rx580 is when
compared to the fastest GTX 1060 tested
here it was 14% faster and that's the
largest performance discrepancy seen so
far even the rx480 Lays waste to both
GTX 1060 models in this title Total War
Warhammer has been tested exclusively
using direct X12 and this appears to
hand a rather large performance
advantage to the radon gpus that said it
is interesting to note that even with
the lowlevel API the AMD gpus do dip
down to lower frame rates despite
delivering stronger average performance
honestly the experience seemed very much
the same using any one of the four
graphics cards tested though looking at
the figures you might assume the GeForce
graphics cards provided the smoother
experience the RX 580 was just 3% faster
than the rx480 and mir's Edge Catalyst
When comparing the average frame rate
while the minimum was exactly the same
this then meant that it was 4% slower
than the GTX 1060 the new 9 GB per
second version of the GTX 1060 also
offered nothing new in terms of
performance for this title F1 2016 often
provides competitive results and we see
this once again when comparing the rx580
and GTX 1060 this time the RX 580 was
able to deliver 7% more performance than
the rx480 at 1080p which placed it on
par with the GTX 1060 Deus X mankind
divided is an AMD sponsored title though
is often the case with time Nvidia has
been able to better optimize their
drivers for improved performance the GTX
1060 is roughly on power with the rx480
now and again we see that the 9 GB per
second model has nothing extra to add as
a result the RX 580 enjoyed a reasonably
comfortable win here leading the GTX
1060 by a 9% margin if there's one thing
that gets nerds rolled up more than
thermal paste application it's testing
games that support direct X12 using dx11
well aware of the risks this is exactly
what we've done when testing Battlefield
1 the dx12 performance is still a little
off in this title it's a bit strange and
we often see lower minimums with the
radio on graphics cards so again we are
sticking with dx11 for this Title Here
we see that the rx480 and GTX 1060 are
pretty well even at both resolutions the
RX 580 though is still able to pull
ahead thanks to a 6% performance
Advantage hitting 91 FPS on average at
1080p as they so often are the Mafia 3
numbers are interesting the radon gpus
are clearly faster at 1080p while oddly
they struggle to match the GTX 1060 at
1440p focusing on the 1080p numbers we
see that the rx480 is 10% faster than
the GTX 1060 while the RX 580 is 15%
faster so a clear wi frame D here then
at least when looking at the 1080p
resolution anyway here's a 44 might be a
direct X12 title but it was also
sponsored by Nvidia so take this dx12
performance with a grain of salt
typically you would expect the radon
gpus to perform well in a dx12 title but
here we see the RX 580 trailing the GTX
1060 by 133% margin once again though we
find the upgraded memory doesn't help
the GTX 1060 out Titanfall 2 has always
played better on Hardware from the red
team though to be fair this game isn't
terribly demanding and plays well on
pretty much anything that said at 1080p
the RX 580 was 12% faster than the
enhanced GTX 1060 we also saw a 7%
increase over the older rx480 in this
title civilization 6 is a lot like ashes
of singularity in the sense that it
mostly CPU performance as you can see we
are mostly CPU Limited at 1080p once we
move to 1440p though the GPU starts to
become the performance limiting
component and here we see the rx580 is
able to deliver 9% more performance than
the GTX 1060 AMD did a great job of
optimizing their software for Call of
Duty infinite Warfare and have led
Nvidia in this title from day one
typically this is a hugely popular
series and therefore a big win for AMD
of course knowing AMD is luck it
shouldn't be a surprise at this
installment of the Call of Duty series
tanked with an alltime peak of just
15,000 players that's less than half the
already underwhelming figure from the
previous title Black Ops 2 for example
peaked at over 70,000 concurrent players
anyway Call of Duty shortcomings aside
the RX 580 does very well here providing
177% more performance than the GTX 1060
that said the RX 580 was just 5% faster
than the rx480 the r on RX 580 was
around 13% slower than the GTX 1060 in
Dishonored 2 in fact the RX 580 only
just broke the 60 FPS barrier at 1080p
while the GTX 1060 only dipped to 55 FPS
so a clear win for the Nvidia gpus here
then Watch Dogs 2 is the third AAA title
release last November that we test with
and it's certainly one of the most
demanding on system resources the RX 580
was just 8% sold in the GTX 1060 here
and once again it did only offer very
mild gains over the rx480 around 5% more
frames the RX 580 ensures that you'll
have the crap scared out of you at the
highest possible frame rates of any
midrange graphics card in Resident Evil
7 here at 1080p the 580 was good for an
average of 107 FPS though that did make
it just 4% faster than the 480 more
importantly though the RX 580 was 15%
faster than the GTX 1060 and this
allowed for a smoother experience at
1440p The Honorable thing to do here was
enable a fair fight and this is exactly
what pona does performance was very much
the same across all four gpus tested so
not much else to say here visually the
game was maxed out so it was nice to see
over 60 FPS at all times when playing at
1080p released in March 2017 Tom Clan's
Ghost Recon wildlands is a very
demanding open world title that said at
10 we saw very respectable frame rates
using the very high quality preset once
again the rx580 was just a few frames
faster than the rx480 here we see a 5%
bump for for what is essentially a mild
Factory overclock the 9 GB per second
GTX 1060 was even more underwhelming
though the standard GTX 1060 was still
able to best the RX 580 in this total
that said the margins were slim at 1080p
while there was nothing separating them
at
1440p also released in March we have
mass effect Andromeda and like forona
this title provides very competitive
results performance at 1080p using the
ultra quality preset was good though the
game did feel a bit laggy at 1440p on
all the graphics cards tested finally
the last game tested is also the most
recently added to our battery of
benchmarks Warhammer dawn of War 3 this
game was tested with the latest AMD
display driver which advertised a 7%
performance boost for the RX 580 the rad
on gpus were most impressive when
looking at the minimum frame rate as the
RX 580 was 133% faster than the GTX 1060
previously we saw in configure with the
rx480 that our system consumed around
10% more power than the same system
figure with the GTX 1060 here we see an
11% increase that figure is increased by
a further 10% with the RX 580 which
pushed total system consumption to 344
wats this meant that the total system
consumption was 22% higher with the orus
rx580 than it was with the EVGA for the
win plus with Peak consumption still
well under 400 wats for a system running
a 7700k at 4.9 GHz the RX 580 is hardly
a power hungry Beast still for those
seeking maximum efficiency the GTX 1060
is clearly the better option here right
then that's the easy bit taken care of
time to pick a winner actually maybe
I'll just end the video there and let
you guys f it out in the comments now
what the hell you guys are going to do
that anyway so I might as well give you
Steve's 2 cents first let's see how they
compare when averaging the data across
all 27 games tested here we see that
overall the 9 GB per second gaming X+
model was no faster than the EVGA for
the win plus the very model we've been
using for all our GTX 1060 testing this
means overall the rx480 was just 2 1/2%
slower than the GTX 1060 at 1080P or 2
FPS so a negligible difference then the
RX 580 boosted performance by just 5%
which made it just 2 FPS faster than the
GTX 1060 or again 2 1.2% so overall the
RX 580 was faster than the GTX 1060 albe
it by an insignificant margin if we
remove the direct X11 titles and focus
solely on those that support lowlevel
apis we see the GTX 1060 and RX 480 are
roughly on par with one another that
said the RX 580 is now 6% faster than
GTX 1060 not a huge margin by any means
but still a clear win for the red team
in those more modern titles now let's
take a closer look at where the big wins
and losses were had for each team right
away it's interesting to note that AMD
took the lead in the majority of the
games tested 15 to nvidia's 11 while
they drew in just a single title that
said margins were extremely Slim in
OverWatch for honor and F1
2016 the RX 580 was faster by a 10%
margin or greater in Total War Warhammer
Titanfall 2 Mafia 3 Resident Evil 7 Call
of Duty infinite Warfare and doom
meanwhile it was 10% slower in just
three titles being Dishonored to Gears
of War 4 and Grand Theft Auto 5 so in
terms of performance they are very
similar that said out of the box the RX
580 is slightly faster though of course
it uses quite a bit more power as well
if you were to base this comparison on
the suggested retail prices the RX 580
seems like the obvious choice the MSRP
has been set at $230 us for the 8 GB
model while the GTX 1060 costs $250 for
the base model and there is no MSRP for
the 9 GBS per second models but they do
tend to be more expensive currently most
rx580 models are priced at $250 us so we
really need to see a price correction
here that said there is a powercolor red
dragon model selling for
$230 but the gigabyte orus model we
checked out currently costs $280 which
is a bit rich in my opinion meanwhile
the GTX 1060 models also started around
$230 though again most are priced around
$250 the evj for the win plus model that
we use for testing also costs $280 while
the new 9 GBS per second model from MSI
cost an eye watering $290 us so again
you really could go either way it really
comes down to the games you play and the
features you want to take advantage of
in this mid-range affordable Market
segment amd's freesync which is now very
widely supported is a huge selling point
AMD has also been making a heap of noise
in regards to their radon chill feature
and while it does seem to work quite
well I have to admit this is a feature I
would never enable or use on my own
personal gaming rig so AMD probably
offers better features at this price
point namely their freesync but it
doesn't exactly seal the deal it's
interesting to look back at the rx480
versus GTX 1060 battle and see how
things have evolved our day one GeForce
GTX 1060 coverage compared these
mid-range gpus in 28 games back in July
2016 and at the time the GTX 1060
dominated winning in over 85% of the
titles tested to beat the rx480 by a
convincing 12% margin however just 5
months later we did retest with 19 games
some of which were newly released titles
at the time along with amd's Crimson
relive drivers the result did see AMD
close the margin significantly and now
the GTX 1060 was just 1% faster than the
rx480 in other words performance was
much the same on either GPU then fast
forward another 5 months which brings us
to today we have more new games new
drivers and even new graphics cards well
refreshed graphics cards as you just saw
the GTX 1060 is still a fraction faster
than the rx480 but the new overclocked
580 model has enough in the tank to get
one up on the GeForce graphics card for
me a efficiency really is important and
this is why I've been a huge fan of
nvidia's Pascal architecture that said
this latest comparison I have found
myself drawn more towards the rx580 and
I think this is the card I would be
picking up if I was in the market for a
sub $300 us mid-range graphics card the
fact that it was faster and the majority
of games tested and the widespread
availability of really good freey sync
monitors has pushed me in favor of the
red team of course there really is no
wrong choice here and could have easily
Justified picking up the GTX 1060
instead needless to say though the
competition is extremely fierce in the
sub $300 GPU Market well that's it for
this one I picked up the RX 580 so time
to let me have it in the comments if you
enjoyed this video why not smash the
like button and if you appreciate our
content and can afford to make a small
donation each month then please check
out our patreon account link is in the
video description on that note a big
thank you to our patrons especially
those to help to refine the selection of
games we used in this video finally hit
subscribe if you haven't already this
will ensure you don't risk missing any
big Benchmark videos I'm your host Steve
see you again soon
[Music]